do you feel like a lot of uh comedians
especially when you're getting started
were you getting hit on left and right
is that something that uh yeah for
experiences yeah non-stop oh they want
to [ __ ] me they're trying to [ __ ] me
they're trying to [ __ ] me yeah and did
you go along with that at all well I
when I first started comedy I gotten
advice from this guy who doesn't really
do comedy anymore but
he was like don't [ __ ] Comics he's like
when you're first starting like just
don't be the girl that's [ __ ] Comics
which
in a way was good advice but also it's
kind of like what are you gonna wear up
late we're laughing we're having fun or
whatever but I had that in my head so I
did resist it as much as possible right
because you do want to just you don't
want the [ __ ] where you eat yeah in a
lot of ways but I did I hooked up with
and I dated a lot of comics I dated
comedians throughout my career but did
you end up hating them
I don't hang out with them anymore I
mean there's some that when they
approach me I go
just you know
vibrationally is no match anymore it
just was a thing it was but it was nice
when I was there you know it was right I
you know but I did date I dated a guy
when I was in doing open mics that was
just a horrific person you dated a guy
that you met an open mic yeah when we
were when we were openmakers and how
well how old were you when I was like 25
right six and
he was just not a good guy how so very
mean to my parents very mean mean to
your parents how is one mean to
someone's parents what would one do uh
yell at them
he yelled at my mom he yelled at your
mom how far into the relationship before
he yelled at your mom we dated for like
a year or so it was probably it was
probably eight months in because I
remember I stayed with him but I hated
him I had trouble saying no and I didn't
want to like hurt people's feelings even
though I seemed like a real [ __ ] but uh
um but I really so I just really it was
a self-worth thing and I would just stay
with these people and and just ride it
out
you just write it out just to see if it
worked trying to fix them do you think
you're trying to fix them I think I just
didn't want to be mean
you didn't want to be me all right well
that's commendable I guess but it kind
of it it it's not good now I mean
looking back on it but I was thinking
about how I told that camp story and I
you know I was the one that did the
whole thing I I feel like I I don't
always paint the picture fairly enough
these were just people living their
lives like I crashed the wedding
I attack I like I went after to [ __ ]
this guy I had not seen or know if I had
chemistry with like they were all
innocent really you just went after it I
just went after it you own up to it yeah
it's my fault the whole thing is my
fault and then I go on like TV and I'm
like talking [ __ ] and stuff so you know
it is
they got into the Annie storm but I have
the Annie storm is it is it difficult do
you think you're easy to do uh to date
do you think that's one of my boy dating
a comedian well I think it just has to
be the right temperament
um I was very like anxiously attached so
I would get really
kind of like obsessed with people or
like very like clingy or needy or come
up that way sometimes or I just didn't
like the person at all and I just was
kind of like using them as a placeholder
and I think the relationship I'm in now
is like so good because he's so securely
attached he's just like comfortable in
himself he has a crazy mom so he knows
how to
deal with wild women you know do you
talk about him on your in your sets yeah
I do and how does he feel about that he
likes it he likes it he forgives he lets
me do whatever I want he doesn't have
anything even if it's sexual yeah it
doesn't
um
well I don't say like mean I don't have
mean things but he's got a small dick my
boyfriend yeah that would be he probably
wouldn't like that but um I don't I
don't like talk [ __ ] on him really I
mean I tease him a little bit he's good
he like he's
he's uh we're having a good life